salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
vous connaissez l'histoire les
dinosaures ont disparu il y a 66
millions d'années à cause du météorite
mais ont-ils vraiment tous disparu
aujourd'hui on s'attaque à un colce mais
vraiment très très cold il y a 66
millions d'années la Terre est le
théâtre d'un événement qui va
bouleverser son histoire une météoride
géante file dans sa direction à la
vitesse vertigineuse de 72000 km/h cet
énorme caillou de plus de 10 km de
diamètre finit sa course sur l'actuelle
péninsule du yukatan au Mexique le choc
est d'une violence inoui il creuse un
cratère de 180 km de diamètre la
puissance dégagée par l'impact
représente l'équivalent de plusieurs
milliards de fois celle de la bombe
d'Hiroshima ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'un tel objet s'écrase sur la
Terre mais cette fois les conséquences
sont inédites la disparition des
dinosaures des animaux qui règnent sur
notre planète
depuis des millions
d'années les dinosaur pas celui-ci
ceuxci ont vécu sur Terre durant l'air
Mésozoïque c'est une période qui a
commencé il y a 250 millions d'années
qui s'est terminé il y a 66 millions
d'années avant on disait l'air
secondaire ils ont régné pendant plus de
160 millions d'années c'est une très
longue période pendant laquelle les
espèces qui nous sont les plus
familières n'ont pas forcément cohabité
le T-Rex par exemple qui a vécu entre 68
et 66 millions d'années n'a jamais
croisé le diplodocus et pour cause il a
disparu il y a 145 millions d'années
mais comment on sait tout ça il y a pas
de Pierre Tombal presque on connaît leur
existence grâce aux nombreux squelettes
fossilisés plus ou moins complets qui
ont été retrouvés le premier décrit
comme tel a été découvert près d'Oxford
en Angleterre en 1815 il s'agit d'un
mégalosaurus que les scientifiques de
l'époque on prie pour un lézard géant
depuis on en a déterré des milliers un
peu partout sur la planète des noms que
vous connaissez bien le Tyrannosaurus
Rex le tricératops le vélociraptor mais
ces spécimenses ne constituent qu'une
infime partie des dinosaures dinosaur
étymologiquement terrible lézard désigne
non pas une espèce mais un super ordre
composé à ce jour de près de 1900
espèces très différentes
il y a autant de différence entre le
petit
compsoniatus de 3 kg à peine le poids
d'un chat et
l'argentinosaurus qui pouvait atteindre
100 tonnes et mesurer 40 m de longueur
qu'entre un éléphant et un chien chez
les mammifères certains dinosaures
étaient herbivores le tricératops par
exemple d'autres Carnivor comme le Trex
et même omnivore comme le galiminus
galiminus c'est mignon non au début de
la vidéo je vous ai dit que les
dinosaures n'avaient peut-être pas
disparu c'est vrai que lorsque l'on
observe un crocodile ou un varant de
commodo on se dit qu'il y a un petit
terre de
famille d'abord ce sont des reptiles le
crocodile est recouvert d'écailles en
kératine comme l'était partiellement ou
complètement les dinosaures les œufs des
uns et des autres possèdent une membrane
amniotique qui protège l'embryon ben
alors et bien ça ne suffit pas pour
faire du crocodile ou du dragon de
commodo un dinosaure ce classement
repose sur des détail très spécifiques
l'un d'eux se trouve au niveau des
membres inférieurs sur l'humérus cet OS
possède une crête particulière qui
n'existe pas chez les autres reptiles la
position des pattes est également
différente chez les dinosaures elles
sont placées sous le corps et non sur
les côtés comme chez la plupart des
reptiles enfin quand ils en possèdent
les serpents ont perdu les leurs depuis
longemps mais chez leur ancêtres ell se
trouvait bien sur les côtés du corps
quoi qu'il en soit ce que l'on
suspectait d'être des descendants des
dinosaures n'en sont pas il faut
chercher
ailleurs revenons à notre météorite elle
a percuté la terre il y a environ 66
millions d'années dans l'imaginaire
collectif tous les dinosaures alors
disparu presque instantanément sous la
violence du choc sauf que les dinosaures
n'ont pas disparu du jour au lendemain
ce processus a mis du temps beaucoup de
temps environ 32000 ans en réalité
la disparition des dinosaures n'est pas
uniquement liée à l'impact lui-même mais
au bouleversement du climat et donc de
l'écosystème qui a engendré cet impact
on l'a dit il a creusé un cratère de 180
km de diamètre mais il déclenche aussi
de violen séisme et des tsunamis
gigantesques qui eux aussi font beaucoup
de victimes ce n'est pas tout le choc
booste l'activité volcanique de la terre
la quantité de CO2 que dégagent les
volcans dans l'atmosphère augmente
provoquant des plus acides l'effet de
serre devient lui aussi plus important
des mégasincendies se déclenchent un peu
partout CO2 plus chaleur entraîne aussi
l'acidification des océans et une perte
de la biodiversité parallèlement un
nuage de poussière enveloppe la terre et
la plonge dans la pénombre moins de
lumière moins de photosynthèse les
plantes ont beaucoup de mal à vivre
l'herbe et les feuilles se font de plus
en plus rares les herbivores trouvent de
moins en moins de nourriture et
disparaissent les uns derrière les
autres puis les carnivores qui n'ont
plus rien à se mettre sous la dent au
final 70 % des espèces vivantes sont
rayé de la carte c'est ce qu'on appelle
une extinction de masse 70 % mais pas
toutes dans ce chaos certains animaux
vont malgré tout réussir à tirer leur
épingle du jeu les mammifères ils sont
déjà présents au moment du choc et ceux
qui vivent partiellement sous terre vont
pouvoir survivre à ces bouleversements
ils sont charognards insectivor granivor
certains ne sont pas plus gros que des
souris c'est le début de leur règne qui
se poursuit encore aujourd'hui mais les
mammifères ne sont pas les seuls à s'en
être sortis et à s'épanouir encore
aujourd'hui je vous l'ai dit au début de
cette vidéo des dinosaures ont survécu
au cataclysme regardez cette poule et
quoi c'est une poule un autre oiseau ce
sera plus clair le casoar et alors et
bien comparons le squelette du casoar
avec celui de lanzu wi qui vivait il y a
66 millions d'années au nord du
continent américain vous ne trouvez pas
qu'il y ait un petit terir de famille
mais oui du coup ça ressemble aussi au
squelette d'une poule évidemment ce lien
de parenté entre la poule et le T-Rex
n'a pas été établi tout de suite un
premier indice est déterré en 1861 45
ans après la découverte du premier
fossile de dinosaur vous vous souvenez
le mégalosaurus cet indice c'est
l'archéoptérix
le fossile fait penser à un dinosaure il
a des griffes une mâchoire couverte de
dents asserrées mais il ressemble aussi
beaucoup à nos oiseaux avec ses ailes
couvertes de plumes c'est sûr cet animal
là saavait volé aucun doute c'est
l'ancêtre des oiseaux mais les
scientifiques s'interrogent il y
aurait-il un lien entre les dinosaures
et les oiseaux les seconds seraient-il
les descendants des premiers pendant
plus de 100 ans aucune réponse n'est
venue pas la moindre découverte pour
étayer cette théorie et puis en
1996 le verdict tombe en fin en Chine
dans la province du Liaoning les
paléontologues viennent de mettre au
jour un fossile de dinosaures très
particulier il porte des plumes il est
très différent de l'archéoptérix on
l'appelle dinosaure nonaviare mais cette
découverte démontre que les plumes
constitue un caractère physique de
beaucoup de dinosaures le lien avec les
oiseaux était établi récemment la
découverte de fossiles comblant les
trous de l'arbre généalogique et de
nombreuses analyses ADN ont fini de
prouver cette théorie du coup les
scientifiques imaginent différemment
l'apparence des dinosaures oublierz son
allure de dragon le Trex était
probablement recouvert de plumes
d'ailleurs certains chercheurs pensent
même que les dinosaures émettaient des
sons plus proche du cri d'un rapace ou
du roucoulement d'un pigeon que du
rugissement d'un félin ça fait moins
peur nom sachez que des scientifiques
cherchent actuellement à réveiller
certains gènes endormis des poulets pour
tenter de redonner vie au dinosaur le
projet s'appelle ironiquement chicken
zurus alors qu'en pensez-vous je suis
sûr que désormais vous regarderez
différemment les poules et les pigeons
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à liker et à vous abonner excellente
fin de journée bonne semaine et à
dimanche prochain pour un nouveau sujet
épicurieux
et